so what other anime takes you have yeah
you told me this garbage one okay okay
this one this one's a spicy one okay so
a lot of people have opinions on Attack
on Titan uh on like whether it's
fascists or Communists I don't care uh
about that I like Attack on Titan a lot
I think it's very interesting
it's the only I'm not a big fan of this
genre but it's the only Mecca anime I
watch Attack on Titan is a Mecca anime
technically technically it could be okay
technically it could be but if if aot is
not Mecca then what about Eva Evas
see I
there's a popular organic they're aliens
okay second of all like I I don't know
Ava for me is really weird because it's
like at first glance it tries to present
itself as a Mecca yeah but then the
further you go along you realize it's
not a Mecca it's just a [__] sci-fi
you are controlling a flesh Mecca in
almost an identical way uh that you
would control an Eva literally literally
you're controlling or piloting something
or is it more that it's kind of
technical because I would think Mecca
comes from Mecca originally comes from
there is a separate mechanical thing
yeah that a person goes into that they
control to become part of them
Attack on Titan they are the mix okay
because you're Japanese what what do
they call this genre in Japanese because
Mech is like a mechanical that's from an
English word what do they call it in
Japan maker yeah Mecca as well yeah
Mecca oh sure yeah it's from like a
mechanical term yeah yeah it literally
it's talking about things like you know
Gundam and like yeah right kind of big
yeah like like you know like some human
going into a robot that is there before
they go into it yeah right then they're
just taking English so [__] maybe
yeah yes yes
it's funny because I know a lot of Mega
fans get so pissed off at this yeah dude
whenever I talk about this like I'm like
I'm no fan of mechanimate except for aot
people go what how dare you say that but
it like it makes sense just think about
it is not dead it's kind of a troll you
don't really care for the boundaries of
what is in what genre yeah because I
guess is you know this is how you're
gonna this is you're gonna come to terms
with the argument by saying it sucks but
like whatever
extend the definition of Mecca to
include that it's a flashback that's why
I say flesh Mecca yeah yeah because like
if you if you don't think Attack on
Titan is a Mecca then Ava's not a Mecca
in my opinion because it's all organic
material
um you know that the mechs that they
pilot uh are you know real organic
beings and they are I don't know this
that's if you never watch it you've
watched David I've watched it don't miss
that part to be fair it is it does get
very confusing
19 plot twists back to back but they
mentioned that during the not confusing
part oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
might have just forgotten kind of like a
yeah I probably just thought there was a
robot do you do like a fundamental part
of the whole thing I don't remember
where the robot goes berserk
um oh yeah I remember that and then the
armor like falls off
yeah oh okay I do remember this yeah
yeah sorry I just I just thought they
were still robots Okay well in that
convention right a Mecca could basically
be like some person controlling
something
yeah kind of yeah so would you say vtube
is a Mech is then
here's what I think here's what I think
the difference between like a Mech and
Attack on Titan is right like if you if
you picked up a sword and started using
it yeah right it's not the same as if
you [__] spouted out a sword from
your arm like your arm just turned it
like transformed into us right right
it's fundamentally different right
because you're you're having this use
the blade and wield it right I think the
fact that you can get out of it like the
fact that you can get out of it
afterwards like I think that like makes
it that solidifies it for me as like a
Mecca because I know what I mean like if
we're gonna talk about control systems
and Mecca there are so many different
control systems in like Mecca when it
comes to either just you know mechanical
controls or you know something more kin
to Ava and in the case of Attack on
Titan it's like we we can argue that the
control system is just them becoming the
body are we really gonna go down this
round of like creating sub-genres
[__] arguments oh my the umbrella term
is Mecca but this is the sub-genre of
Flesh I just I think that it fits it
fits the the same like style also very
political apparently yeah I just like
all the other Mecca animes are from what
I understand yeah it is yeah yeah yeah
like has no one ever like presented this
to the to the mangaka no one wants to
hear it I just like this
people get mad but like searching for
who Hassan who asked yeah well I don't
know I'm asking for cast I think he just
wanted to make a cool story yeah but uh
yeah I'm asking when it's gonna end
that's what I'm asking well final season
part three hopefully hopefully next year
is I'm I'm hoping out of hope I'm hoping
I don't know man there's not even that
much material left in the monks dude
they're gonna milk the [__] out of it
like as if they haven't already I mean
like yeah I I I I'm I said it was going
to be this year but it's gonna be nice
it's not gonna be nice yeah guys I'm
saying it now it's gonna be next year
there's only so many chapters left
there's not that many chapters left so
honestly they go an original route and
go something completely different from
the manga then it's going to be there's
not that much material does that happen
often I don't know not So Much Anymore
it used to be a way more popular thing
to kind of uh take what was in the manga
and a lot of times manga wasn't finished
so they just make their own original
ending I mean Akira did that yeah Kira
did that yeah Metal Alchemist did that
even though I haven't actually seen the
original Fullmetal alchemistry full
metal Alchemists yeah yeah the original
Trigon did that as well actually I think
uh Fullmetal Alchemist the newer version
is better than this
yeah that's common yeah that's common
yeah I've watched it like I've watched
both
Jesus
you're coming to terms with some of the
things I'm saying I feel like I'm
putting it down because Brotherhood it's
not coming to putting it down and you're
picking it up okay what other [__] takes
do you have what else do I have I have
like notes okay
no I have like I mean I have one where I
just like I call it the Zelda principle
this one's like spicy but I feel like
Zelda which is not an anime but it's
still like still you know Japanese art
video games yeah where I feel like Zelda
doesn't have to be 17 but they say she
is and it's like that's one thing where
I'm just like why did you say she's 17
like they say it like multiple times
throughout the game they like they're
like but know that she's 17 I'm like
well you didn't draw her like that
like what why do you have to like you
just say she's 18. it's fine it's the
same age range you know what I mean yeah
I mean I hate this stuff too have you
ever watched uh Tokyo uh revenges no
it's about like biker gangs and they
beat and uh kill each other uh but that
the full team
well and then you have JoJo which is
like yeah which which is hilarious
because like no one even thinks that
they're 15 and it's almost like a joke
it's like a self-referential joke where
it's like cool he'll just be like I'm 15
by the way and he's like built like a 35
year old man who's like taking steroids
of the past tense Bucky that's the same
thing right now I'm a cold is 15 but
he's like [__] tatted up like or
scars everything in part three yeah he's
17. yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and they
and they point to it and you're like
okay well that's just silly like I just
I I feel like at that point you almost
just disregard the age because like the
age is obviously just [__] yeah of
course like because the car like what do
you take more because online there's
always this discussion of but the
characters this age it's like well if
you're we're talking personality and
locks of the character determine more of
the the age or is it purely whatever the
guy says it is yeah no you got dudes
with like full facial hair and they're
like yo I'm I'm 17 by the way make sure
you understand I'm 17 I'm like no you're
not what the [__]
I think it was weird you would not get
carted hahaha
yeah I think what's weird is when you
have something that looks like that
um you know you know you could say
they're 50 and it's like a joke whatever
but when it's like you have something
like that and then they put them in high
school it's just like there is no
[__] way this guy is in high school
that's what I loved about the beginning
of part three when Joe Tara goes back to
school yeah
how are you in high school Ryan it's
like six seven and it's just like yeah
he's just so jacked and so much bigger
than everyone else
hahaha
it's [__] up yeah I love it it's like
oh man all these assassins are coming
and trying to kill him in high school
it's weird